tens of thousands of new refugees have
poured into Chad from westar4 the latest
and perhaps clearest sign violence
inside Sudan is getting worse
[Music]
civilians abandoning their homes in
exchange for their lives
only to find themselves almost
immediately in another fight for
survival
their chadian hosts try to allay fears
but the situation here local officials
say is getting out of hand
well why then if they don't get tense if
they don't get water and food if they
don't get clothes to wear they will die
at this place just as you see them now
I'm asking you to help these people
help is coming but slowly Aid agencies
the local government military and police
all agree they haven't seen anything
like this so far since the conflict
began if we just walk over here you can
get a sense of how enormous the scale of
this humanitarian crisis is the tense in
this makeshift Camp they just keep going
and going really this represents an
enormous humanitarian challenge ahead
how scarce everything is how remote this
place is and how little these people
fled with really means that the
humanitarian crisis ahead the challenge
ahead is enormous
fighting in cartoon between Sudan's Army
and the paramilitary rapid support
forces is destabilizing the whole
country but the conflict is complex
Sudan in general and Darfur particularly
have long been the scene of ethnic
fighting hitting arabic-speaking
communities against African ones exactly
who is behind the latest violence in
West R4 remains unclear
perhaps the truest picture comes from
the refugees
the Arabs are killers they killed a lot
of people
they took the cows and scare the
children away people left without
finding their children
I don't know maybe the dad of thirst or
hunger we didn't lose any children but
they killed my uncle the children over
there their father was killed
people living in these camps lack the
most basic provisions
it is a struggle to perform simple tasks
and being in this place requires Grit
still they say it is better to face
thirst hunger and homelessness than the
barrel of a gun
and so they keep coming eight agencies
expect numbers to surpass previous
estimates the rains are coming too
without adequate shelter they risk
disease illness more misery
the humanitarian crisis sparked by the
conflict in Sudan
is spilling over
Zain basavi al-jazeera borota Eastern
Chad